monsterwellen kleine viel öfter als
gedacht zu geben wenn diese studie
stimmt dafür zahlreiche schiffe nicht
sicher und können leicht auf eine
monsterwelle treffen und versenkt werden
wie oft sie auftauchen wo jetzt
berechnet und das ist alles andere als
beruhigend science fiction herzlich
willkommen
259 etwa katar vor der südafrikanischen
küste 211 menschen sterben in dem schiff
nach dem eine monsterwelle es beschädigt
hatte und es zu mehreren explosionen
kommt das wird aufgrund von
beobachtungen vermutet 178 das straff
münchen örtlichen akteuren 28 seeleute
ertrinken ursache eine monsterwelle 182
die bohrinsel ocean ranger im
nordwestatlantik 84 vorleute wurden beim
untergang der plattform in die fluten
gegriffen oder kranken 2008 der
japanische fischkutter super-mario
nummer 58 östlich von japan nur drei
fischer überlebten und anderen 15 der
frachter champ j acht männer gehen mit
dem schiff unter eine monsterwelle
brachte es zum kentern und die reihe
ließe sich wahrscheinlich beliebig
verlängern nur bei vielen verschwundenen
schützen weiß man einfach nicht was mit
ihnen passiert ist die augenzeugen will
alle tot monsterwellen könnten oft die
ursache sein
190 karten monsterwellen oder wie die
leute sie nannten kadenz männer als
seemannsgarn also geschichten erfundene
war erschien 464 ein erster fahrer zum
thema nur ein jahr später entwickelte
afrika von professor der physik an der
universität turin eine theorie und
berechnungsmethode für das phänomen
verwandte die quantenmechanische
schrödinger gleichung an um die
nicht-lineare ausbreitung der wellen zu
beschreiben doch er verwarf diese
berechnungsmethode bis ja bis 1995 die
wirklich erste monsterwelle zweifelsfrei
beobachtet werden konnte im februar des
jahres wurde ein lasersystem auf der
nordseeinsel de fündig während eines
sturms mit rund fünf meter hohen wellen
wird eine monsterwelle gemessen aus dem
nichts taucht eine 26 meter hohe welle
auf die existenz von monsterwellen ist
seitdem bewiesen die gäste monsterwellen
kommt das ist inzwischen relativ gut
untersuchte langsame wellen werden von
schnellen bällen überholt und männer
besonders ungünstig geschieht dann
schauten sich die wellen gegenseitig auf
ein vielfaches ihrer ursprünglichen höhe
auf aber wie oft das geschieht das war
bisher unklar bisher
jetzt haben alle karin magnusson vom
norwegischen meteorologischen institut
und macdonald von der university of
miami aus den usa genauer untersucht und
sind auf ein erschreckendes ergebnis
gestoßen dafür haben sie einen ganz
bestimmten sturm genauer untersucht den
andreas sturm in der nacht des 9
november 2007 trug dieser sturm über der
nordsee
diego fünf plattformen messen mit ihrem
lasersystem mehr als 13.000 wählen die
analyse der daten brachte jetzt das
schier unglaubliche ergebnis zu tage
monsterwellen entstehen weitaus öfter
als bisher vermutet ein jeder stelle im
meer taucht alle drei wochen eine
monsterwelle auf in ein sturm können es
bis zu zwei am tag sein da wunder
geschont dafür mehrere hundert jahre
gedauert hat sich die beobachtungen von
wehrleuten durch die wissenschaft
bestätigt werden konnten und das bei
einem phänomen das er direkt vor unserer
nase täglich stattfindet wie wir jetzt
wissen auf jeden fall sollten sie jetzt
die schiffbauer mehr gedanken machen wie
sie unsere schiffe sicherer machen
können denn auch kreuzfahrtschiffe wie
zb die briten sind auch heutzutage noch
betroffen
das schiff wurde am zweiten februar 2001
von einer 30 meter hohen monsterwelle
getroffen eine halbe stunde liebe es mit
40 grad schlagseite manövrierunfähig im
sturm auf weg nachdem die mannschaft
einen höchst wiedl und das bei diesem
wetter wieder zusammengebaut hatte
konnte das schiff wieder einigermaßen
flott gemacht werden und wurde dann als
pfarrer in den hafen von buenos aires
geschleppt und repariert wäre der
mannschaft die reparatur nicht gelungen
wäre die bremen damals wohl
untergegangen getrunken werden dabei
mehr als 200 menschen
starker tobak und kein seemannsgarn
diese geschichte mehr starke geschichten
seht ihr wenn ihr euch die playlist best
auf klicks um anschaut dafür hier
klicken und wenn er mir hier ein abo
aufs auge drückt verpackt sie auch kein
video mehr gibt es ja seit kurzem
täglich nicht vergessen wir dabei einen
auf die glocke zu geben aber hier
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
platzt